so i don't know how many of you remember
it was uh a really big day in my life
but it may not have been in your life uh
about a month ago i i did a breakdown of
rick scott's 11 point plan to save
america
and this was it was notable because
it sort of seemed like in a sea of
cultural issues and
talking points that make no sense
a republican was actually putting
together a policy proposal and this is
the republican florida senator rick
scott so we looked at it the proposal
was absolutely absurd incredibly if if
rick scott got his way
the policies he proposes would be
incredibly damaging to the country a lot
of them weren't even really policies
they were just again cultural issues
masked as policy but we reviewed it
because it was actually something
apparently substantive from republicans
and it was a crazy and disastrous
proposal
rick scott went on fox news and
on fox news reporter john roberts calls
out rick scott for some of the things in
his plan and it's not you know that john
roberts is the be-all end-all of
journalism or whatever but here
he did a good job of saying here's stuff
that's in your proposal
rick scott tries to call them democratic
talking points and john roberts is like
no no no it's straight out of your
proposal and it is and rick scott
doesn't know what way you know what is
up what is down it doesn't make any
sense
this is how
flaccid these proposals are where as
soon as they are questioned about them
they say well those are just democratic
spin
no it's in your proposal check this out
because putin's such a thug a murderous
thug
all right uh let's switch to politics
now because there's a lot that we've got
to look forward to between now and
november the 8th you recently put out an
11-point plan to rescue america
two of the big points of which are quote
all americans should pay some income tax
to have skin in the game even if a small
amount currently over half of americans
pay no income tax it also says all
federal legislation sunsets in five
years if a law is worth keeping congress
can pass it again
so that would raise taxes on half of
americans and potentially sunset
programs like medicare medicaid and
social security
why would you propose something like
that in an election year
sure when john that's of course the
democrat talking points it's a little
bit no it's just a plan
it's in the way but here's but here's
the thing about reality for a second
first let's talk about everybody senator
john so it's not a democratic talking
point it's in the plan
and also in the plan okay so now notice
how he first said it's it's a lie and
then when he
can't say anything other than well yeah
it is in the plan he says but there's
also other things in the plan now what
john roberts is saying is is true
um when rick scott says everyone should
pay at least some federal income tax you
have to remember there are lots of
people that end up paying no federal
income tax because between
a low income
and the standard deduction
and child tax credits and whatever you
end up paying zero federal income tax
now
we have to remember these folks pay a
lot of other taxes they pay sales taxes
they pay uh excise taxes if they have a
vehicle they have car registration fees
they may pay state taxes it's not that
they don't pay taxes this is a popular
right-wing talking point
to say the rich are paying so much
and half the country pays no taxes well
okay you you're entitled to child tax
credits and the standard deduction etc
but it is part of their
talking point as to why the tax system
needs to be changed rick scott is then
confronted well that is going to
increase taxes
for half of americans per your own
favorite talking points and rick rick
scott says well that's that's democratic
propaganda no it's actually in your plan
then he switches to well here's other
stuff that's also in my plan says we
ought to every year talk about exactly
how we're going to fix medicare and
social security here's what's happening
no one that i know of wants to sunset
medicare social security but what we're
doing is we don't even talk about it
medicare goes bankrupt in four years
social security goes bankrupt in 12
years i think we are remember that
they've been using these bankruptcy
talking points for a long time and
they're all completely untrue to figure
out how we preserve those programs every
program that we care about we ought to
stay stop and take the time to preserve
those programs now understand what he's
saying here
he claims i don't want to get rid of
social security and medicare no i don't
want to do that but i do want us to
debate whether to keep them on a regular
basis so let's re phrase what he's
saying
he's saying
i want it to be on the table that we
might gut or eliminate social security
and or medicare
that he wants that possibility at least
i i mean i just fought the postal bill
because it put more responsibility on
medicare and took it off the postal
service and put medicare in a worse
position
now let's go back let's talk about taxes
for a second i'll put my record up
against anybody on tax cuts i tax i cut
taxes and fees a hundred times as
governor but now understand that that's
such a meaning i don't even want to
waste time on this but this is how
politicians lie where he goes well
listen when i was governor i cut taxes
and fees 100 times you guys understand
that that can mean okay um he's cutting
the vehicle
registration fee from 50 to 45 that's
one cut
he is changing the uh
excise tax rate from 1.05 percent to
1.03 that's a second cut
these are sort of meaningless statements
and politicians are so good at just
off-handedly mentioning them here's
what's unfair we have people that don't
that could go to work and have figured
out how to have government pay their way
that's not right so that's actually what
this is about that's actually what this
it's about it's about cutting welfare
and all sorts of different programs so
understand that
the republican
there's some people who say oh
republicans want to
kill americans by putting people in
genocide camps or whatever and then some
republicans say it's democrats who want
to put people in genocidal concentration
camps or whatever no no no the way it
works is republicans want to slowly chip
away at programs that enable people
to live in a dignified way
and take away the ability of folks to
afford
unexpected costly events or just the
cost of being alive
and
this is the way they do it listen we we
should look at
whether medicare really makes sense to
keep we should justify whether social
security should keep going we should
look at food stamps we should make sure
that everybody's paying some federal tax
which means the poor make the poor pay
more in taxes that's how you do it it's
not you know these these 1984-esque
uh fema camps or whatever else it's it's
these little little cuts to take away
people's dignity and um
certainly i don't know how much the fox
audience realizes the dishonesty and the
absurd nature of what rick scott is
proposing and his complete inability to
defend it here um but the best way to
dismantle all of these so-called plans
is you go line by line
and
explain to them
this is what it would do
how do you justify it half the time
they'll say that's not really what's in
my plan and then you go no it is here it
is and then the other half they'll just
explain it away with very
transparently bogus talking points